c'est le chiffre et mois qui passaient
des vacances coup quand j'étais petit à
côté d'ici avant à l'omtv antibes
j'ai mon père était venu de russie il
voulait retrouver un peu l'ambiance de
la fim et la crimée oui c'est la merde
quoi saisir pool house lahoud a été
glaciale mis le tard et je n'en sais
rien
deux jours plus tôt vous de la crimée et
ça correspondait un roux climat d'ici ou
d'antibes de nice cannes et il a cherché
mon père était avec sa bulle apparaît
jeu je pleurais fait c'est vrai qui est
arrivé
de plus mais il a su qu'ils partaient
mettez à miami de jeunes officiers
élèves et 10 heures son père et sa mère
aujourd'hui on ne voit plus jamais
va-t-en c'est plus possible les rouges
vont arriver et il est il éthique le
chien à constantinople en six mois être
un bateau qui l'a amené à gafsa galles
sentent musique était un département
français les bleus alors il d'arriver en
france et il a eut rencontré ma mère en
1942 par jean rostand qui était un mec
formidable l'utilisé pas céder là j'ai
rencontré un génie genre l'instant j'ai
passé par exemple 10 heures avec urgent
laboratoire où il y avait 2500 bocaux
des tritons avec des royaumes et on va
les chercher ensemble des revenus de
tomber dans l'est dans les étangs est
temps que je n'avais pas compris si vous
voulez me dire c'est lui qui était un
conte elle génie comme j'en reste encore
1,6 avis sur tout et ça c'est magnifique
quand à 8 ans et tu vois un mec comme ça
qu'il ya des cheveux blancs qui prend le
temps d'expliquer jusqu'à jeter compris
et c'est là où j'ai compris que la
connerie humaine n'a pas de limites et
qu' il faut être dix mois lorsqu'il très
drôle dans cette histoire c'est que ton
père a acheté antibes en viager la
méchante baron de ville d'avray pcva
rond était malade que ton père est venu
sans son toubib et s'est occupé de lui
et qu'il l'a tellement bien soigné c'est
que il a vécu c'est le sera également le
dire mon père avait un drôle de viager
parce qu'il a quand même duré jusqu'à
100 ans presque oui mon père un tour et
j'ai pas d'argent mais regagne un peu de
pognon on paiera jamais gagné mais ma
mère n'a jamais su ce mon père y est tu
as jamais vu et il n'a jamais suffi que
la mort était avec sa vue des russes
merde j'ai pensé tout on sait pas
comment mais ils avaient envie d'en
trouver ça
son pays et quand il est arrivé à
antibes il a trouvé cette maison en
viager que le baron de ville d'avray 38
de la rue avait 77 ans sacha brest - 15
ans est é la politesse de mourir besoin
après que nous raconte le gabon dragons
de l'existant l'accent hongrois et lui
ne voulais que mon père médecin veut il
avait 77 ans et on a vécu pendant 20 ans
dans la cave de notre maison
les choisit d'en acheter alors le baron
avait tout le reste
quel merveilleux baron d'ailleurs lui en
veux pas parce que mon père est de 125
il avait vu des 90 1 c'était humide
c'était son vous avez passé 22 ans la
cua où l'on se dit j'ai vu mieux on en
vient merveilleux l'endroit a des
souvenirs de vacances de l'époque c'est
la pêche avec ton père tu partais à 5
heures du matin aux trois heures et puis
c'est la fin de l'hiver et cap d'antibes
à l'époque c'est à dire c'était pas
comme maintenant et je pouvais te
raconter dit ce qui se passait à juin
n'est pas vaincu région à l'époque des
régions l'église et qui laissait 100 ou
200 mecs dormir avec lui ont décerné
tout germain des prés et brutalement il
y avait claude lutter s'il l'aimé jette
a prévu des festivals de diane c'est pas
savoir où tu es magnifique et sur la
plage la tâche des pirates à jour les
pins on finissait avec la contre-basse
j'ai vu un jour dizzy gillespie jouer
assis dans une boue et de la trompette
donc selon bah si c'est vraiment un
temps d'expliquer de diplômés
aujourd'hui j'ai connu ce existe pas
d'une magnifique
jeudi c'était avance à 3 pc avec bardot
oui j'en ai peint intégrant la station
jaguar c'était cette époque un jour ton
père tu pars à la pêche s'était sur
pattes à l'elysée
par la pêche tout de suit en vélo sur
les remparts et tu tombes
comment tu sais ça je sais tout ça mais
c'est une histoire extraordinaire parce
que tu tombes et très jeune je faisais
loin pour eux de montrer c'est en fait
c'est mon frère qui m'a dit j'ai ma vie
c'est pas ma mère tout le monde croit on
demande toujours qui auraient plus de
poids face aux poteaux ma mère a
toujours dit que les enfants n'étaient
pas si 15 humains
est ce que mon père dirigeait ma vie et
je l'aimé je suis chez boris et file
vers 5 heures du matin 6 heures je fonce
au port je m'étais pas réveillée
et puis heureusement je ne t'asseois yom
un jeu les remparts d'antibes et je
tombe de 6,7 mètres de haut et j'ai vu
une chose je sais pas si tu l'as vu déjà
à toi ces contrats je te raconte des
choses de la vie
le film devrait certainement jamais non
jamais et je veux mais tu as les yeux je
suis tombé la tête en avant des remparts
d'antibes en vélo comme un monde et j'ai
vu une journée magnifique dire que tu
vois les plus beaux moments de ta vie un
comme un film en couleur à mourir et
j'ai réussi à savoir pourquoi je dis
bien sportif à l'époque de ton plaisant
mais j'ai placé les deux jambes mais
j'ai vu ma vie en couleurs
et j'aurais vous nouerez et je suis
tombé dans les bras d'un pote à moi
j'étais pompiers auxiliaires de 17 ans
qui m'a amené j'ai vu ce pote va mourir
devant - un an après en plongée il
beaucoup de choses qui sont faits
quelques mc cain tu vas garder de cette
jeune belge au jour là c'est devenu gros
oui j'y vois aussi je suis aucune idée
je sais pas si c'est une grande douleur
puisque le tome 1 tick loupé un juif de
dieu quand j'étais jamais disant ouais
mais bon ça m'a aidé dans la vie parce
qu'après l'été intérim j'étais d'une
aucun gène les un tournoi à 14 ans mais
j'avais 10 ans et j'ai grossi abattu un
gros site
disons que je devenu graisseux que
j'étais vraiment heureux